as movie fans everywhere mourn the
passing of ray liotta it's only natural
to take a look back at his career and
what could have been
there's an interesting lost role in
particular that's worth exploring
here's the major superhero role ray
leota regretted turning down
rayoza is known for his work in gritty
crime dramas often playing an anti-hero
or a good cop gone bad
as far back as i can remember i always
wanted to be a gangster
the actor played a fictionalized version
of new york city mobster henry hill and
martin's course says he's critically
acclaimed goodfellas startup said kurt
russell's sociopathic police officer in
unlawful entry and stood out amongst the
star-studded cast in the sylvester
stallone led copland
but that doesn't represent the entirety
of his body of work before gaining a
reputation for his neo-noir roles the
actors starred in the action comedy
something wild and played the ghost of
famous baseball player shoeless joe
jackson in the kevin costner starring
fantasy drama field of dreams the
outsider has also lent his voice to
popular video games like grand theft
auto and won an emmy for his guest
appearance on the long-running prime
time medical drama er he had a venerable
career most actors would kill for but
it's always intriguing to consider what
might have been of all the roles he's
taken on for the big and small screens
there's one in particular that lyota
regrets not exploring playing batman has
become something of a badge of honor for
actors in the same way actors have taken
on iconic roles like hamlet and macbeth
others have portrayed the dark knight
over the years it's an exclusive club
and one that frequently entices debates
about who's the best batman of all time
interestingly enough lyota could have
been part of those conversations had he
chosen to take a meeting back in the
1980s
in a 2016 interview at the los angeles
times to talk about his work on nbc's
shades of blue
lyoto recounted the time his team
received a phone call from tim burton
who would go on to direct 1989's batman
in the mid-1980s burton gave the otas
agent a call while the actor was filming
something wild and asked if he would be
interested in both meeting him and
auditioning for the title role in his
then upcoming batman movie he recalled i
think tim burton is a great great
director and they always regretted not
going and meeting him just to talk
superhero films weren't widely popular
then and lyoto admitted that he thought
it was silly at the time the role
ultimately went to michael keaton who
had just starred in burton's beetlejuice
a year before and would reprise her role
in 1992 for batman returns
even though ray liotta wasn't too keen
on playing batman back in the 80s it was
still a highly coveted role
after all batman was already a household
name at that point and tim burton was
one of the most promising up-and-coming
directors suffice to say plenty of
actors likely auditioned for the role of
the caped crusader and fans loved
ruminating on what might have been had
the role guns of someone else other than
michael keaton what are you
i'm batman perhaps most intriguingly of
all william defoe was considered for the
part of bruce wayne given his eclectic
and provocative performances it would be
easy to believe that the foe would have
been better suited to play joker back in
the day but according to the actor in an
interview with mtv news he auditioned
for the dark knight it's unclear how far
along in the casting process to foe got
but we do know someone else in
contention for the part james bond actor
pierce brosnan according to brosnan
drawing a reddit ask me anything i went
and met with tim burton for the role of
batman but i just couldn't really take
it seriously any man who wears his
underpants outside his pants just cannot
be taken seriously that was my foolish
take on it it was a joke i thought but
how wrong was i these actors weren't
alone in their audition processes mel
gibson was reportedly also sought after
for the part but he had to turn it down
due to his commitments to lethal weapon
2. these are all many intriguing
what-ifs but ultimately it's perhaps
best to roll when to michael keaton
who's still considered by many to be the
definitive batman
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]